Dave Portner you guys know Dave Portner
from Barstool Sports who knows a bit
about these exchanges and a bit about
the market and what's going on he was at
Tucker Carlson I was actually downstairs
from them right there I was having a
burger over at the Hard Rock uh Diner he
was on Tucker Carlson at the Hard Rock
Hotel Hollywood just a couple days ago
explaining like hey is anyone going to
pay for any of this Billy get to the
bottom of what happened no no I mean I
don't know that will truly know what
happened because there's a lot big
players have probably lost a lot of
money I mean the bankruptcy today what
they release is crazy what they were
spending money on but who knows I never
think we'll know anything I don't want
to be some conspiracy when there's big
money involved I never think I'm getting
a straight shake like I mean honestly
how can Gensler sit down with a guy who
is living in a penthouse in the Bahamas
with 15 people who are all having sex
with each other spending money on
everything and he's like yeah we're
going to write the legislation with you
I mean I was honestly how is that
possible I can't tie my shoe this guy's
doing that and getting away with like
come on to the White House let's sit
down and you know make some legislation
it's insane yeah so there's a lot of
weird stuff it was like they were having
orgies and all this weird stuff and this
idea that bankman freed was helping
Democrats write legislation related to
crypto he was doing something that was
against the very nature of crypto if you
talk to anyone that knows anything about
Bitcoin or cryptocurrencies again this
idea of the centralized uh exchange is
nuts you would want it all to be
decentralized but they have a
centralized guy so he's into control
writing the laws about cryptocurrency
which is completely counter to the very
ethos of cryptocurrency in the first
place but this thing this FDX thing it's
everywhere it's affecting and
infiltrating I would say even the world
governments that seem to be coordinating
in some sort of Call Me Crazy conspiracy
theorist I'll be proven right in two
years some sort of uh globalist agenda
we've got some info here from the New
York Post the shocking implosion of the
FTX crypto exchange has become an
embarrassment for a who's who among
Global elites with some issuing Maya
culpas and other apparently scrambling
to hide their ties to its disgraced 30
year old founder Sam bankman freed web
archive sites show that the world
economic Forum shocker whose glitzy
shindig in Davos Switzerland is a must
attend for billionaires
and world leaders each year had
previously listed FTX as one of its
Partners touting the bahamas-based firm
as a cryptocurrency exchange built by
Traders for Traders bankman freed also
was a speaker at Davos last May along
luminaries such as Google financial
Chief Ruth poret and Bill winter CEO of
the london-based financials Giants
Standard Chartered nevertheless World
economic Forum has since scrubbed any
mention of FTX from its website in the
days after the crypto exchange filed for
bankruptcy do you think this is all
weird do you guys think the timing of
this thing is weird there was this giant
Ponzi scheme money laundering machine
that made it all the way to the election
being the second largest Democrat
donoring structure
donation structure and then it implodes
the day after the election and then the
world economic Forum which we know
basically puts world leaders in
positions of power in different Western
governments then they scrub ftx's
relationship off their website within
three four days do you think this is
weird